(Clock ticking)
(School bell ringing)
I want everyone to answer this
question, alright?
I'll give you a second to
think about it.
Now, raise your hand if you
think you're a lucky person.
Just Ramon.
Okay, raise your hand if you
think you're unlucky.
Got it. Okay, put your
hands down.
♪♪
Student:
What about you, Mr. Corman?
What's that?
Student:
You didn't raise your hand.
Me, uh..no, I...I mean, I feel
like a lucky person.
(Singing)
I'm having anxiety or panic or
something. Both.
(Screaming)
Victor:
What's the difference?
I'm gonna need a sub for
today.
(Singing)
Victor:
What's bothering you?
Everything.
It just feels like I blew the
whole thing, like I suck as a
person.
You're not entitled to a
perfect partner or a perfect
life.
(Singing)
I didn't leave you because you
became a teacher.
I left because I thought I was
doing what I love with the man
I love.
♪ To see me through ♪
Ruth:
How was your weekend?
It was great.
Oh, you're some big man now!
You guys walk away.
(Yelling)
(Glass shattering)
(Bell ringing)
Alright, good morning.
Happy Monday.
♪♪
Everything is a complete
disaster.
You have the privilege of
expecting everything to just
work out.
Now that you're
faced with some adversity...
Mandy:
It could feel like the end of
the world.
You want to stop feeling like
you're feeling?
Victor:
What about this weighted
blanket?
It costs two-hundred fifty
dollars.
We can make our own version.
You can't make your own
version.
You feeling less anxious?
No, I'm really not.
♪♪
You can't stop thinking about
all the things you should've
done and why you didn't do them.
♪♪
♪ When I was a boy ♪
Josh:
I know I can be negative
sometimes.
♪♪
It's not how I want to be.
♪ Now I wonder how ♪
Ruth:
Nothing is perfect.
I don't know why that's so
hard for you to see.
♪♪
Ruth:
The question is, what do you do
now?
♪ When your name is just a name. ♪
♪ Name is just a name. ♪
♪♪
♪ Just a name. ♪